[Music]  welcome back to cbs this morning here's  a look at some of this morning's  headlines  axios says a white house source leaked  president trump's private schedule  from the last three months while the  schedule does not show all of mr trump's  meetings it indicates he has spent about  60 percent of his time  in unstructured executive time axios  sources say much of that is spent in his  private residence watching tv  reading the papers and phoning aids and  other people in response press secretary  sarah sanders says while the president  spends much of his average day in  scheduled meetings events and calls  there is time  to allow for a more creative environment